[Music]
i'm dana bobinger a neuroscientist at
the mcgovern institute at mit
i study perception or how the brain uses
the senses to understand the world
around us
when your senses are activated your
brain has sent clues about what's out
there in the world usually your senses
give you lots of clues and your brain
pieces these clues together to figure
out the complete picture
but sometimes the clues aren't so clear
and your brain has to make a guess about
what's out there based on your brain's
assumptions or expectations
so if you change your expectations you
can actually change your perception
here's what i mean
i'm going to play a sound and i want you
to listen for this word
[Music]
you've probably heard brainstorm
now i'm going to play the exact same
sound but i want you to listen for these
words
[Music]
you probably heard the words green
needle this time
that's because the audio quality of this
clip isn't clear and your brain made an
assumption based on the clues it was
given
you can visit our website to experience
other illusions and learn more about
perception